[Music]
let's go to jolene in baton rouge
louisiana what's up jolene
hey how are you outstanding how are you
i'm great excellent so how can i help
what's going on
um i've got a question i've been married
for 27 years and um i i think i'm done
i'm kind of working on a divorce plan
and i hate it i don't want to do that
but um and i want to know how i can help
my kids
how come why are you done
what happened
um
it's been going on for a long time um
we we've run a business together and
now i'm i'm kind of doing it on my own
and he has another job and um i just
it was pretty good before we had kids um
and he's uh you know after we had kids
he just he wouldn't help at all with the
kids he kind of just we would work side
by side with the business all day and
come home at the end of the day and he
would grab a beer and go sit on the
couch and everything was left up to me
and so i just kind of dealt with it and
i got really resentful for a long time
my kids are 14 and 16. and um
when i was pregnant with my youngest
i asked him you know i kind of had a
breakdown i said i'm really tired i
can't do this by myself i really need
you to help me and um you know i mean i
just i need you to participate and and
be part of the family
and um and i don't know where he came up
with this but he told me he said you
know i'm just a bad dad i'm just a bad
husband you need to find somebody that
makes you happy
and
you know i didn't know what to think you
know and the first thing i did was say
you know no you're not a bad dad you're
not a bad husband
you know i just i just need some help
and um he's i know he had a really bad
childhood there was a lot of abuse there
he watched his dad abuse his mom and um
and they're still together so um
you know and
i just i don't know how to deal with
some of the things he's saying i don't
really feel safe with him anymore
and so
i i feel like i've got to kind of work
this out and and make a plan in private
like you know on on my own and not
really let him know what's going on and
i feel really bad about that you know
doing that on my own and not
not telling him but i just i feel like i
have to
and um and my kids have seen some things
they probably shouldn't have what have
they seen and
um
they've seen him you know this is my
oldest but um
he and i'm sorry i've never told this
i've never said anything to anybody
about this before i've kind of kept it
myself um
everybody thinks she's a great guy and
we have a great marriage and and it has
been for the most part but there's been
some pretty dark things that have
happened what did your son see
we got an argument one night um i just
didn't feel like having sex i wasn't in
the mood i was trying i asked him to put
a different movie on or something he got
mad got an argument
i went to go sleep on the couch
and he came out and um started choking
me put his hand on my face
and my son woke up and saw it and told
him to quit hurting mommy
and um
that was a long time ago and that
doesn't happen very often
but um
you know he just
jolene
jolene yeah
yeah
take a big deep breath and hold it
okay hold it
hold it three
two let it go
now your shoulders are bunched up around
your ears right now once you just drop
them down
okay
okay
you don't have to apologize for him
you don't have to make this
you don't have to minimize this
you're not you're not
bad
you're not broken
you're married to somebody who hurts you
yeah
and you're married to somebody who's
hurting your kids either directly or
indirectly
yeah
and does he have some demons oh
absolutely
yeah he does hold on hold on hold on
hold on hold on hold on you're coming to
his defense you're running to his
defense he doesn't need you to defend
him okay
he's got demons for sure
but that's a context not an excuse
he doesn't get to hurt jolene
jolene's worth being loved
jolene's worth sleeping all night
feeling safe
yeah jolene's worth not feeling like
having sex sometimes
jolene's not is worth not worrying about
her boys being safe
okay
hey
have you ever said the words out loud
i'm done to anybody other than me
no
okay thank you for sharing that
thank you go figure go home right
i will share with everybody
you can't do this by yourself do you
have somebody that's walking alongside
you
um
i've got an appointment with the
counselor next week um and i'm doing all
that behind his back which makes me feel
really guilty but um i need to i i love
him
yeah yeah
you are not safe
oh no
there's nothing to feel guilty about
now i will never tell somebody you
should get divorced
know i'm not ever going to do that i
don't ever want to come back and say i
did this because you told me to
but you're not safe
and you haven't been safe for a long
time
you need to go talk to somebody today
okay i know you made an appointment with
the counselor i need you to talk to your
lawyer today i don't know what you start
thinking about divorce i'm saying about
that
if you're down this road you need to go
talk to a professional
and be on the way
in your head if you start adding it up
and thinking about it and building it up
building it up you're having
conversations in your head that nobody
else hears
yeah
but that disconnection that annoyance
that resentment
that starts to be felt everywhere your
kids feel it and your husband feels it
your clients feel it your customers
everybody feels it
and that's where we get a lot of
problems that's where we get the
blow-ups and the whoa where did that
come from and people say things they can
never take back and they do things they
can never take back
when you first started this call you
said i think i'm done so i'll ask you
directly are you done
i am i don't want it i don't want i
don't know i know i know i know i know i
know i know and nobody wants this
and what made me start to feel that way
is i got to thinking i don't want to be
married to him when my kids are grown up
and gone
i just don't and then i felt bad for
feeling like i'm standing behind them
and making them
um
you know i guess protect me because
they're around he's you know i guess it
puts the brakes on some stuff sometimes
and it doesn't happen very often but um
but it happens
yeah it happens and um and and the
threat of it happening
is violent too
the cloud of
it could go off at any moment
is violence
12 year olds step walking on their tippy
toes because they don't know when dad's
gonna set off on mom is violence yeah
and i've come to my kids defense too and
then they apologize for me getting you
know for for them dragging me into it
you gotta get out jolene
yeah you're not safe or he's got to go
and
somewhere along the way
somebody told you that your feelings
didn't count
that your job was to make sure everybody
else was okay
and i may be the first person to ever
tell you this
but what's happening to you is not okay
and you don't have a thing to feel
guilty for
and nobody wanted this
you'll grieve that later
you'll grieve the crap out of this later
but today is about safety
today's about my boys will not see this
my boys will not have to get between
their dad and their mom ever again
my boys will not walk through this house
and wonder is dad gonna
smack one of them
how do i talk to them why mean i
i don't want them to grow up and be the
same way i want to put a stop to this
right now but i don't want to run their
dad down to him
i don't want to make him feel like their
dad's a horrible
they already know that
they already know
your young son already had to say daddy
quit hurting mom
they know yeah
what they need is a different picture
about what dignity and respect and
treating a wife actually looks like and
they don't have that picture
no
of a woman that says no more this is
what love looks like this is what
connection looks like this is what it
feels like to have a good night's sleep
and not worry about whether something
bad is gonna happen to mom
they've never felt that
ever
and so the greatest thing you can do for
your boys right now is be safe
because they are absorbing a hurricane
inside that house
yeah
you've heard the old
fight or flight you know that was
designed for when a bear came to a cave
dr nadine burke harris she's got a great
story that she talks about
you know the bear came to the cave and
your body's designed to go into fight or
flight but it's designed for a quick
burst
happens really fast and then it's over
you either kill that bear you run away
from that bear that bear eats you
that's about how that thing's designed
we don't have a biological system for
what happens when that bear moves in the
house
and we are on fight or flight every day
every minute of every week
and you deserve better than that
your boys deserve better than that
and
i hope this isn't controversial your
husband deserves better than that
yeah no he he does i just i don't know
how to help him that's not your job i'm
leaving him behind but
honey
he left you a long time ago
i know
he left you a long time ago
and now you have to be the grown-up once
again and go through the paperwork
and figure out what the finances are
gonna look like and how the business is
gonna get split up and it's gonna be
hell
yeah that's what i'm telling you gotta
have somebody walk with you not just a
counselor but you gotta have some
friends do you have some friends that
you can count on
i really don't all of our friends are
both of our friends and they think he's
a great guy and i'm just
i don't know i'm afraid they're going to
take sides you know because they don't
see what what we see they will and that
still doesn't mean you don't do the
right thing
yeah i don't say the right thing that
sounded like i was getting onto you
i'm like doing a safe thing
yeah okay
and
i'm heartbroken for you but you know
what
so answer your question
what are the things how do you talk to
your boys
you tell them
mommy has not been safe you don't have
to mention your husband at all mommy's
not been safe
and we are going to find we're going to
either live here without dad
or
we're going to get a new place however
that plays out that's between you and
the lawyers and the mental health
professionals and all that
but we're going to go to a place where
we're safe
and we're going to develop a set of
family values that we're going to live
by
and
there's going to be problems in school
because they're going to lash out and
you're going to love them and connect
with them and hold them accountable and
they're going to struggle academically
they're going to struggle socially all
those things are going to happen and you
know that you're not going to get
frustrated and be caught off guard by it
because they grew up in a an abusive
household
and
you're going to continue to love them
you're going to continue to hold them
accountable and you're going to have to
figure out groups in your community you
have to figure out connection in your
community
and this is going to be hard and in this
case heart is right
you deserve safety jolene
you deserve love
you deserve to be able to laugh
and be able to say
not tonight honey i'm not feeling it
and not have some man's hands around
your throat
do you believe me
okay
it is it is but it's also gonna be
i don't think you fully exhaled in years
i know you haven't
and
i want you to make one switch for me
okay
you're a peacekeeper
that's why people love you you make sure
everybody else has something to eat you
make sure everybody else's drink is full
you make sure everybody else is you go
to somebody else's house for dinner and
you help them clean up am i right
yeah
i want you for the first time in your
life
to start treating jolene like you treat
everybody else
you are worthy of you loving you
you're worthy of saying no that hurts
you cannot do that
you are worthy of saying you will not
talk to our boys that way you will not
hit our kids you will not hit me in
front of those kids i will not let them
grow up in this environment
i will let you be a grown-up and figure
out how you're going to pay rent how
you're going to find your own place that
is up to you
as for me and my house we're going to be
safe and we're going to have peace and
we're going to have laughter back and
we're going to open the shades back
i want you to start treating jolene like
you treat everybody else deal
thank you so much for your bravery thank
you so much for your call
i cannot i cannot tell you this enough
julian
get somebody to walk alongside you today
even if it's one of those friends that
you're like on the fence one of those
friends has a wife
who knows
one of those friends has a wife
or
somebody who
just has their suspicions
reach out and
sit down with that person and say i need
you to walk alongside me because things
are about to get messy for a season
and we'll be with you the whole way
jolene don't hesitate to give me a call